Another reason I'm really mad that my car got busted like this
is because I just got this wireless car charger.
You clip it to your car, it has a cord that connects to your outlet,
and then it's mag safe. So you just attach your phone to it,
and it'll charge your phone hands free.
Super easy, you know,
like clicking in and out or anything.
So I can't wait to try it.
I don't even know when my car is gonna be done,
cause they found even more damage.
So the original estimate that the insurance companies gave them,
they're like, ooh,
you hit the nail on the head.
Well, we gotta add a little bit more,
so there's even more damage.
So Lord knows when I will ever get my car back.
But if you want one of these, let's link right here.